السلام عليكم ورحمه الله مشاهدينا الكرام
اهلا بكم في الحلقه التاسعه من تغطيتنا
لاحداث عام 2014 نتوقف اليوم مع شهر
سبتمبر الذي كان شهر الحدث اليمني بامتياز
حيث دخلت القوات المواليه لجماعه انصار
الله المعروفه باسم جماعه الحوثي العاصمه
صنعاء من دون قتال يذكر وسيطرت على الوضع
الامني هناك بينما بقي الرئيس عبد الربو
منصور هذه في السلطه في معادله ظلت غير
مفهومه
للكثيرين وقبل التوقف لمناقشه هذا الموضوع
بالشرح والتحليل نستعرض معا اهم ما شاهده
شهر سبتمبر من
احداث يبدا شهر سبتمبر في يومه الاول
بتدفق اعداد هائله تقدر بعشرات الالاف من
اللاجئين في شمال سوريا على الاراضي
التركيه اكثر من 130 الف نازح معظمهم من
الاكراد ينضمون الى نحو مليون اخرين
سبقوهم الى تركيا مما يخلق وضعا انسانيا
صعبا في المناطق الحدوديه التركيه مع
سوريا في الثاني من سبتمبر ينفذ تنظيم
الدوله تهديده باعدام صحفي امريكي ثان هو
الصحفي ستيفن
سوتلوف الذي كان قد خطف في سوريا عام
2013 وياتي ذلك بعدما تعرض تنظيم الدوله
لهزيمه كبيره في منطقه امرلي الواقعه بين
بغداد واربيل والتي حاص صرها لاكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر وفي العاشر من سبتمبر يقرر
الرئيس الامريكي تنفيذ ضربات ضد تنظيم
الدوله في سوريا بدعوى انقاذ النازحين
الفارين من التنظيم لكن بدء الضربات يتاخر
حتى الثال عش من الشهر بعدما اعلن تنظيم
اعدام رهينه بريطاني من عمال الاغاثه وتتم
الضربات بمشاركه عدد من الدول
العربيه في الثاني من سبتمبر يبدا
الحوثيون دخول العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء ويتم
توقيع اتفاق بينهم وبين الرئيس عبد الرب
منصور غادي في الحادي والش ب الشهر نفسه
مع اكتمال سيطرتهم على العاصمه يسمى
الاتفاق اتفاق السلم والشراكه ويخول
الحوثيين تسميه رئيس الحكومه لكن الحوثيون
الحوثيين يواصلون الاعتراض على بنود
الاتفاق لتزداد حده العنف وتمتد من منطقه
الى اخرى في ال من سبتمبر يتم تنظيم
استفتاء في اسكوتلندا لتحديد ما اذا كانت
ستعلن استقلالها ام تبقى جزءا من المملكه
المتحده وتاتي نتيجه الاستفتاء برفض
الانفصال بنسبه
55% بينما يؤيده
45% من
المصوتين هذا الهامش البسيط سيخرج
بريطانيا من ازمه كبيره كانت ستواجهها في
حال اختار الاسكتلنديون انفصال وفي ال9 من
سبتمبر يتم تنصيب اشرف غني رئيسا جديدا
لافغانستان خلفا لحامد كرزاي بعد توقيع
اتفاق بين غني وعبد الله عبد الله لتقاسم
السلطه قبل ذلك
باسبوع وبعيدا عن السياسه يشهد سبتمبر
حدثا بارزا على ساحه صناعه السينما اذ
يتاكد تراجع ايرادات افلام هوليود الكبرى
في شباك التذاكر في امريكا الشماليه وجاءت
ارباح هوليود بعد عطله الصيف منخفضه
بمقدار الربع عن
التوقعات ومباشره الان الى مناقشه ملف هذا
الشهر حيث اثار دخول الحوثيين العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء مشاعر مختلفه من الدهشه
والرفض حيث اعتبرت مصادر مختلفه ان ما حدث
كان نتيجه خيانه من جانب قيادات في الدوله
اليمنيه بينما راه البعض امرا واقعا تفسره
حاله الانقسام السياسي الحصل منذ ازاحه
نظام علي عبد الله صالح بمقتضى المبادره
الخلجيه لكن حاله الدهشه والترقب سرعان ما
تبددت لتحل محلها حال تالم لمشاهده ثوره
اخرى من ثورات الربيع العربي تضل طريقها
الى دوامه العنف الذي بات يلف اليمن من
جديد
بينما كان مبعوث الامين العام للامم
المتحده جمال بن عمر يرعى توقيع اتفاق
السلم والشراكه في دار الرئاسه بصنعاء بعد
حوارات طويله اجراها في صعده مع زعيم
الحوثيين عبد الملك الحوثي لعده ايام كان
مسلح الحوثي يحاصرون العاصمه اليمنيه
ويستولون على مؤسساتها الامنيه والعسكريه
استراتيجيه المشهد اذهل الجميع بدءا من
الرئيس اليمني عبد الربو منصور هادي الذي
وصفه المراقبون بالضعيف مرورا بالامم
المتحده والدول العشر الراعيه للمبادره
الخليجيه استغرق سقوط صنعاء بالكامل بيد
الحوثيين يوما واحدا هو الحدي والعشر من
سبتمبر لكن السؤال الذي يدور بعد سقوطها
وحتى اللحظه هل سقطت صنعاء ام سلمت الى
الحوثيين وهل كان الرئيس اليمني احد
المشتركين في المؤم
التي افقدته السيطره على الحكم لم يستطع
احد حتى اللحظه الاجابه على هذا السؤال
لكن المعلومات الموثقه تقول ان تحالفا بين
الحوثيين والرئيس المخلوع علي عبد الله
صالح ونظامه الامني السابق المتمثل في
نظامه العائلي ومساند شكلوا حلفا عسكريا
وامنيا استطاعوا من خلاله تفكيك الويه
الجيش والامن وشراء الولاءات القبليه
المحيطه بصنعاء وقبلها عمران مستفيدين من
حكمهم لليمن خلال 33 عاما ومن امكانياتهم
المختلفه اما المفاجئ فقد كانت تصريحات
السياسيه والاعلاميه الايرانيه التي تشير
الى اشتراك ايران في هذه العمليه وسقوط
العاصمه الرابعه بعد دمشق وبغداد وبيروت
في ايديهم كما
قالوا يوم واحد فقط وبدا الحوثيون في
افراغ مخازن الجيش من الدبابات والمدرعات
والاسلحه الثقيله والنوعيه وسحبها باتجاه
محافظتي عمران وصعده حيث قاموا بنفس
العمليه في المحافظتين واستولوا على مخازن
الاسلحه فيهما وهو ما يجعل قدرتهم
العسكريه اكبر من قدره الجيش اليمني في
هذه اللحظه بسبب افراغ مخازنه من السلاح
وقد ذهب الحوثيون ابعد من ذلك مستمرين في
التحالف مع علي عبد الله صالح فسيطر على
حجه والحديده واحكموا قبضتهم في ذمار
ومناطق من اب ويحاولون السيطره على مارب
والجوف لاستكمال خطتهم العسكريه والامنيه
في اجاه مناطق الشرق والشمال المحاذيه
لحدود
السعوديه الان وبعد بيان مجلس التعاون
الخليجي الواضح في قمه الدوحه والذي ندد
بالحوثيين وسيطره ما وصفها بميليشيات على
العاصمه والمدن اليمنيه تكون الازمه قد
اتخذت منحا اخر ابعاده الاقليميه اكثر من
ابعاده المحليه بعد ان انحصر الصراع
المسلح حاليا بين كيانين الحوثيين
والقاعده بينما تشهد العمليه السياسيه
تراجعا وضعفا رغم كل المحاولات
لانقاذها اذا لمزيد من النقاش حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو
الكاتب والباحث السياسي اليمني عبد الناصر
المودع مرحبا بك استاذ عبد
الناصر نسال هنا هذه السهوله التي دخل بها
الحوثيون العاصمه صنعاء كيف تمت وكيف
نفهمها وماذا وراءها يعني اتت هذه الدخول
الحوثيين بهذه السهوله
نتيجه
تراكمات واتفاقات
ضمنيه او رسميه تمت بين اطراف كثيره
والحوثيين لاهداف مختلفه الرئيس السابق
صالح استخدم الحوثيين كاداه للانتقام من
خصومه الذي قاموا عليه بالثوره وتحديدا
الجنرال علي محسن وولاد الشيخ الاحمر وحزب
الاصلاح الرئيس هادي من جانبه اراد ان
يستخدم الحوثيين ايضا ليقوي مركزه السياسي
من خلال ضرب هذه هذه الاطراف وايضا ضرب
الرئيس السابق صالح
ا المبعوث الاممي لسوء الحظ
ايضا اصبح ضمن من اعتقد بان اضعاف هؤلاء
يصب في مصلحه ال الاصلاح السياسي في اليمن
وبالتالي
ا تغاضى سكت عن تمدد الحوثييين الذي بدا
منذ بدايه العام بدا الحوثيون يتمدد من
صعده وخرجوا من مراكز نفوذهم السابقه
واحتلوا منطقه دماج وكل هذا تم بالسكوت
والتغاضي من قبل الرئيس هادي الذي كان
بامكانه ايقافهم عن طريق الضغط السياسي
وليس الضغط العسكري وكان ايضا المبعوث
الاممي بامكانه ان يوقفهم من خلال تهديدهم
بعقوبات دوليه وبا كيف للرئيس ان ان ان
يوقفهم والحال ان هناك قطاعات واسعه من
قيادات الجيش يقال انها ما زالت تدين
بالولاء للرئيس علي عبد الله صالح
وبالتالي الرجل لم يكن فعلا يملك قرار
المؤسسه العسكريه والامنيه صحيح من
الناحيه النظريه ولكن كما ذكرت كان
بامكانه ايقافهم من الناحيه السياسيه
عندما كانوا في صعده وبداوا يتمدد باتجاه
صنعاء كانوا قد سمح لهم الرئيس هادي
بالعمل بحريه في صنعاء كانوا اصبحوا شركاء
في العمليه السياسيه كان بامكانه ان ان
يهددهم
بانه سيمنع وجودهم في صنعاء وفي بقيه
مناطق اليمن سيعاقبهم سياسيا سيخرج
من اللجان الذي كان
يشكلها كجزء من العمليه السياسيه ايضا
كانوا في وضع ضعيف في ذلك الوقت ايضا ليس
صحيح تماما بان القيادات العسكريه في
اليمن لا تدين بالولا بالمطلق للرئيس هادي
انا قطاعات واسعه في قطاعات واسعه صحيح
انها قطاعات واسعه ولكن لم تختبر عمليا
الرئيس هادي ادعى وحاول ان يدعي بانه ليس
له سلطه على هذا هذه القطاعات لان اجندته
تقوم على ان يستخدم الحوثي كاداه لضرب من
يعتقد انهم المبادره الخلجيه اذا تذكرنا
جيدا من بين الاشياء التي كانت تنص عليها
واعاده هيكله المؤسسه العسكريه بحكم ان
هذه المؤسسه الكثيرون من قياداتها كانوا
مازالوا على او يدينون بالولاء للنظام
السابق ولربما هذا ما كان يستدعي بعض
التغيرات في المؤسسه العسكريه دعني هنا
اسال بنقطه هامه ذكرتها قبل قليل بان
صمت قلت بان الامم المتحده في شخص ممثلها
صمت القوى الاقليميه صمتت والدوليه يعني
كل هؤلاء تواطؤوا من اجل اسقاط العاصمه
صنعاء في يد الحوثيين ام ان الامر كان
مفاجئا
وهه الاطراف لم تكن ربما على علم بالقوه
التي يملكها الحوثيون وفوجئوا وبالتالي رد
فعلهم لم يكن مناسبا لحجم الحدث انا لا
اقول ان الجميع تواضع في سوء اداره للملف
من قبل السعوديه سوء اداره يبدو ايضا
الامريكان والغربيين تفاجئوا بان المال
سيؤول الى ما ال اليه ايضا يبدو ان الرئيس
هادي وجمال بن عمر لم يك يكونوا يريدوا ان
الحوثي يتمدد الى هذا الى هذه الدرجه ا ما
حدث في يوم 21 سبتمبر تحديدا ان حزب
الاصلاح والجنرال علي محسن الذي كان يقاتل
الحوثيين كان
وقواته قرروا الانسحاب من المواجهه حينما
شعروا بان الرئيس هادي قد قرر ان يتخلى
عنهم قرروا الانسحاب وبالتالي فتحت ابواب
العاصمه الامر الاخر قياده وزاره الدفاع
امرت القوات
العسكريه الي كانت تتبع الجنرال علي محسن
بان تسلم اسلحتها وان لا تقاوم الحوثيين
وال والا كانت البلاد ربما ستدخل في دوامه
حرب اهليه طب والبحر من الدماء المبرر
المبرر وجيه المبرر وجيه الذي قدمه حزب
الاصلاح بانه لا يريد ان يواجه الحوثيين
وحده وان هذا سيؤدي الى بحر من الدماء في
داخل منطقه مزدحمه بالسكان بعد بعد ذلك
الحوثيون طالما كانوا يرددون بان هدفه ليس
السيطره على البلاد وليس السلطه وانما
محاربه الفساد وبان بان ما جرى كما
يصفونها بثوره يصفونها بثوره شعبيه ووقعوا
اتفاق مع الرئيس و وقوه سياسيه اخرى سمي
باتفاق السين والشراكه ثم تاخر توقيعهم
وجاء في الاخير توقيعهم على الملحق الامني
الذي كان ينص على انسحابهم من العاصمه
ومدن اخرى وتسليمها او اعاده السلطه سلطه
الدوله لهذه المناطق ومع ذلك ظل الحوثيون
في العاصمه بل وواصلوا تمدهم في البلاد
ماذا نفهم من هذا الموقف من الحوثيين رغم
توقيعهم على اتفاق المشركه الحوثييين من
الواضح لديهم مشروع للسيطره على الحكم
والاستفراد بالسلطه هذا تركيبتهم
وطبيعه حركتهم تقوم على السيطره
والاستفراد بالسلطه ولهذا ليس مفاجئ ما
قاموا به و وليس مفاجئ ما سيقومون به في
حال تمددوا اكثر واكثر هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه اخرى ان الحوثيين كون
الحوثيين لم يلتزموا باتفاق السلم
والشراكه اتفاق السلم والشراكه يحمل في
ذاته الغام وضعها الحوثيون من بينها ان
يتم استيعابهم داخل مؤسسات الدوله وهم
الان يقولون نريد ان نريد ان يتم دمج
قواتنا في داخل مؤسسات الجيش والامن
وبالتالي هذا سيؤدي الى انهم يبتلع الدوله
من خلال دخولهم في داخل هذه المؤسسات
الحساسه شكرا لك الاستاذ عبد الناصر
المودع الكاتب والباحث السياسي اليمني
شكرا لك شكرا لكم كما ينضم الينا من
الكويت الدكتور عبد الله الشاجي استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه الكويت والاستاذ
الزائر في جامعه جورج تاون مرحبا بك دكتور
شاجي
المشهد اليمني بات كما يبدو تحت سيطره
طرفين رئيسيين الحوثيون والجماعات
الاسلاميه المسلحه هل المساله لا تزال
يمنيه يمنيه ام ان الصراع في اليمن تحول
او اليمن نفسه تحول الى ساعه ساحه صراع
نفوذ ومصالح لقوى اقليميه
ودوليه لا طبعا يعني اليمن للاسف يعني
وضعها في وضع الوله ما نسميها الدوله
الفاشله او الدوله يعني المفككه وهذا يعني
يستدعي ان يكون هناك قوى اخرى اقوى من
الدوله الوله يعني بحد ذاتها المركزيه
ضعيفه راينا كيف سقطت العاصمه خلال يوم
والملفت ان عمران التي الى شمال صنعاء
قاومت لمده شهرين يعني فهناك يعني ادوار
للاعبين من غير الدول ودول تتفاعل في
اليمن واليمن ضحيه لكل هؤلاء اللاعبين
الذين لديهم اجندات ولديهم اهداف الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني لم تحرك ساكنا
بسقوط صنعاء بل اهتمت اكثر بكوباني ولم
يصدر عن اي مسؤول امريكي اي بيان الموقف
العربي والاقليمي ايضا كان خجولا ولم يكن
يعني على مستوى الحدث
بيان القمه الخليجيه البيان الختامي يعني
كان فيه نوع من الانتقاد قوي
والمتاخر للحوثيين وسيطرتهم على صنعاء
واحتلالهم لاجزاء من اليمن ولكن اليمن منذ
سنوات اصبحت مرتعا للقوى الاخرى الحوثيين
غير دوله يحتلون الان يسيطرون على اجزاء
كبيره من اليمن بدعم
ومباركه ايرانيه وهذا يعني ان ايران تمددت
وصار عندها نفوذ في جنوب الجزيره العربيه
على حدود السعوديه وكذلك القاعده الموجوده
منذ سنوات اصلا مقر القاعده في منطقه
الجزيره الع العربيه موجود في اليمن والهك
صراع الان يعني كانت الفكره ولا تزال بان
الامريكان يقصفون من الجو والحوثيين
يشتبكون مع القاعده في البر فيعني هذه
المعادله للاسف يدفع ثمنها الشعب اليمني
والامن
والاست اعتقد 2015 سيكون عام صعب جدا على
اليمنيين ايضا لهذا كنت اسالك
استشرافاً وحدته مع تعدد الاطراف
المتداخله
مصالحها
ونفوذها في الساحه
اليمنيه يعني اليمن تركيبه عجيبه رئيس
ضعيف لا يزال موجود في صنعاء رئيس سابق
يتحكم بالمفاصل العسكريه خاصه في الحرس
الجمهوري والمؤسسه الامنيه اي
وفصيل من غير الدوله يسيطر على اليمن
وهناك ايضا فصيل اخر يقاتل هؤلاء في
القاعده خاصه في شبوه وفي الجنوب وهناك
الحركه الانفصاليه الحراك الجنوبي يعني
فكل هذه تتفاعل مع بعض كل هذه اللاعبين او
هؤلاء اللاعبين وكل هذه العوامل تتفاعل مع
بعض ولا يبدو بان هناك يعني بريق امل
باستثناء ان يكون هناك يعني نوع من يعني
حتى الحوار الوطني اللي قاعد يدور الان
غير مجدي في اعتقادي وكنا في مؤتمر قبل
فتره في الدوحه واجتمعنا مع مسؤولين من
اليمن وبعض النواب ويعني يبدو بان الصوره
اي سو دويه ومتشائم كثيرا ان لا يوجد حل
سريع واني خاصه بوجود القاعده وبوجود
الحوثيين وبوجود نظام سابق ونظام حالي تحت
يعني هيمنه او سيطره طرف ثالث يسيطر على
مفاصل كثيره في الدوله واستمرار الحوثيين
بالسيطره على مناطق واخرها في ارحب ايضا
يعزز من قوتهم وسطوتهم وهيمنتهم ويبعد
الحل يعني اي حل يمكن مستقبلي للشراكه
راينا ماذا فعلوا ب مجلس الوزراء ويعني
انسحاب الحكومه وعدم اعطائها الثقه يعني
سيطره امنيه وعسكريه وسياسيه وللاسف يعني
لا يبدو بان هناك في خط افق او ضوء في
نهايه النفق في القادمه من الايام او في
عام 2015 للوضع اليمن الذي مثل ما ذكرت في
المقدمه يعني اجهضت ثوره شعبيه اخرى ثورات
الربيع العربي التي للاسف يعني لا يبدو اي
اي واحده منهم قد حققت ما يصب اليها
الشعوب شكرا لك دكتور دكتور عبد الله
الشاجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت والاستاذ الزائر في جامعه جورج
تاون او جورج واشنطن عفوا من الكويت شكرا
جزيلا
لك في الثام عشر من ايلول سبتمبر كانت
بريطانيا الامبراطوريه التي لم تكن تغرب
عنها الشمس كانت على موعد مع اختبار
تاريخي كان سيعرضها لخساره ثلث
مساحتها حبس الجميع انفاسهم انتظارا
لنتيجه استفتاء نظمه الاسكتلنديون لتقرير
ما اذا كانوا سيستقيل عن بريطانيا ام
سيبقون جزءا منها لكن الاجابه جاءت بفارق
ضئيل برفض
الانفصال قبل اجراء الاستفتاء في
اسكوتلندا كانت السلطه السياسيه ال
تتفاخر بنهجها الديمقراطي وتعتز بوحده
جذورها ولكن قبل اسابيع قليله من
الاستفتاء اشارت استطلاعات الراي الى
احتمال فوز انصار الحزب القومي
اسكتلندي حينها شعر الساسه البريطانيون
بخطر تفكك المملكه المتحده فسارعوا الى
اقناع شعب اسكوتلندا بان مصالحه المختلفه
تقتضي ان يظل موحدا مع
بريطانيا ما بنيناه بالتح معا لا ينبغي
تركه عرضه للتقسيم الذي ينادي به ضو الفكر
الضيق اظهرت النتيجه ابقاء سكوتلندا في
وحدتها مع باقي المملكه المتحده ولكن
بفارق 10% فقط وفيما تمكن اسكتلنديين من
الحصول على تنازلات جديده تعهد لهم بها
الساسه البريطانيون لتسيير شؤونهم بعيدا
عن مركزيه القرار في لندن تصاعدت اصوات
اخرى في انجلترا تطال بالحصول على
امتيازات
مماثله هناك الكثير من الافكار المتداوله
حاليا ولكن لا اعتقد ان اي شيء جدي سيطرا
قبل اجراء الانتخابات العامه اعتقد ان
الساسه البريطانيين سيتعرضون لامتحان ما
بعد الانتخابات واذا لم يلتزموا بتعهداتهم
فسيحدث اهتزاز للاستقرار
الدستوري اسكتلنديين المؤيدون للاستقلال
رغم خسارتهم شعروا بانهم خاضوا تجربه دي
رايه حققوا خلالها مكاسب عمليه بغض النظر
عن نتيجه الاستفتاء وانهم مستعدون لخوضها
في المستقبل لو سمحت الظروف
السياسيه اما الساسه في انجلترا وباقي
المملكه المتحده فقد شعروا بانهم حافظوا
على وحده بريطانيا وعلى مرونه نظامهم
السياسي حتى ولو حدثت مستجدات في المستقبل
العياشي جاب الجزيره
لندن ونختم مراجعنا لاحداث شهر سبتمبر
باخبار هوليوود حيث شهد الشهر الذي يحل
مباشره عقب عطله الصيف حدثا بارزا على
المستوى الفني العالمي فلم تاتي سفينه تلك
العطله بما تشتهيه هوليود كحصن لانتاجها
الكبرى ومنيت عاصمه صناعه السينما
العالميه بانتكاسات كبيره اذ لم تحقق
الارباح التي كانت تامن بها وانخفض الواقع
عن التوقعات بنحو
25% ومع تراجع شباك التذاكر في السوق
المحلي الامريكي كان الرابح الاكبر من
افلام هوليود التنين
الصيني بعد ان تفائلت هوليوود بايرادات
افلامها في العام الماضي والتي اعتبرت
الاعلى في تاريخها وبلغت 11 مليار دولار
هت صيف هذا العام بنسبه وصلت الى
25% ولم تصل ايرادات اي فيلم في الشباك
الامريكي الصيفي الى 300 مليون دولار وهذا
امر لم يحدث منذ 13
عاما بدات اولى ملامح التراجع في
الايرادات مع الفشل الكبير لفيلم ترسن
للنجم جوني ديب ولاحقا مع افلام الشخصيات
الخارقه مثل اكس مان والجزء الثاني من
سبايدر مان وكابتن امريكا التي لم تسجل
مردودا عاليا مثل ما كان
متوقعا وكان ابرز افلام الصيف الهوليوديه
الجزء الرابع من ترانسفورمرز الذي حقق
اكبر الايرادات وقدر ب
241 مليون دولار الى ان الرقم يبدو
متواضعا امام ال 400 مليون دولار التي
حققها الجزء الثالث من ايرون مان اقوى
افلام صيف 2013 ومع هذا التدهور بدا البحث
عن
السبب تراجع الايرادات يعود بنظر
المراقبين الى عوامل عده منها ان
التلفزيون وخاصه اشتراك الكيبل يعيش هذه
الفتره عصرا ذهبيا في امريكا مع مسلسلات
لا تجذب المشاهدين فقط بل وكبار نجوم
الشاشه الفضيه في هوليوود ايضا اضافه الى
ان هوليوود لم تنفق الكثير من الاموال على
افلام عام
2014 ففي العام الماضي انتج 3 فيلما
بميزانيات كبيره مقابل 22 فيلما هذا العام
كما ان السوق العالمي بات يضر ارباحا اكثر
من السوق الامريكي المحلي حيث يشكل اكثر
من 70 في من دخل هوليود لذا فان شركات
الانتاج باتت تاخذ في الحسبان ذوق المشاهد
غير
الامريكي يامل المتابعون ان يعوض العام
القادم اخفاقات شباك التذاكر الامريكي
لهذا العام حيث هناك كم كبير من الانتاجات
الكبرى والاسماء
التي سيكون من الصعب على المشاهدين
تجاهلها مشاهدينا الى هنا ينتهي استعرضنا
واياكم لابرز احداث شهر سبتمبر عام 2014
في الغد بحول الله نتوقف مع احداث شهر
اكتوبر وسيكون بصحبتكم غده عويس من اللقاء
بحول
الله
ا